oh you have to take your shirt off on it  yeah okay go for it so in previous slow  mo guys videos we've seen how flappy our  faces are yep demonstration perfect  that's a good noise only carry on yeah  um so we decided to see what other parts  of our bodies were quite flappy now I  know immediately what you're thinking of  no it's not that  but it is well gab came up with the  ingenious idea for punching someone in  the stomach and surprise surprise  I was the nearest person you were you  were actually this far away from me  and then that was very close all right  are you gonna clench yeah gonna have to  do two and a half thousand frames in HD  Oh  you  [Music]